mobile phone footage verified by two
media outlets appears to show the plane
exploding in the sky just seconds before
it crashed Western leaders say the
evidence points towards an Iranian
missile Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau was the first to publicly
announce the theory we have intelligence
from multiple sources including our
allies and our own intelligence the
evidence indicates that the plane was
shot down by an Iranian surface-to-air
missile this may well have been
unintentional this new information
reinforces the need for a thorough
investigation into this matter US
officials have told US media they have a
quote high degree of certainty that it
was a missile that hit the plane earlier
President Donald Trump had also
suggested it might have been an accident
Iran vehemently denies the theory that
an Iranian missile brought down the
plane the thing that is clear to us and
that we can say with certainty is that
this plane was not hit by a missile as I
said last night the plane was on fire
for more than one and a half minutes in
the air and the location shows that the
pilot was attempting to return has ended
yesterday Ukrainian officials have also
said they were quote not ruling out a
missile attack they have sent a team to
Tehran to investigate and are insisting
on full cooperation
Iran has invited the u.s. aviation
company Boeing to join that probe and
said it would provide visas for
accredited investigators from the
countries involved joining me now is
Nick waters in London he's a senior
investigator at Berlin cat and
investigative collective and welcome to
you now you verified that video clip
that we saw in our report that allegedly
shows the airplane being hit by
something what exactly were you able to
confirm
so it's video last night we worked up
precisely where the video was filmed so
in the city params
and because we knew precisely where it
was filmed we could work out where the
explosion or where the explosion you see
actually was because you can work out
the direction and then you can also work
out the distance as well from the time
that takes from the explosion being seen
on the camera to hearing it but they
also pictures look of missile fragments
circulating on the internet what do we
know about the authenticity of those
pictures so currently there are two
images showing a tall missile head these
have not been verified they do not
appear to have been posted previously
from what we can tell however they
haven't been G located and we can't work
out precisely where these images were
taken so they remain unverified phrases
right because it is suspected that tor
missiles were used to bring down that
plane that is according to intelligence
agencies that we've been hearing from
now they are also reports out there Nick
that bulldozers are being used to clear
the crash side what is your
investigation show so we started hearing
these rumors yesterday which was very
concerning for us because that would not
necessarily be beneficial for the
investigation we have heard i literally
just saw a post this morning from a news
crew have managed to get to the scene
and it appears that the fragments of the
plane have indeed been cleared from the
crash sites I believe this will likely
harm the investigation into this
instance based on the evidence said
you're a sight a web site has collected
what do you think brought down this
plane it is I would not like to say
anything that we cannot confirm we have
a video that shows an explosion above
around we believe we can see a missile
in that video and then potentially an
object possibly a plane flying out from
it and that explosion matches the flight
path of this Ukrainian plane
that is the most I can say because that
is what we have confirmed I would like
to say more than that without side of
information so for the moment based on
the evidence that you have you would not
rule out the Iranian version that it was
a mechanical failure although I cannot
rule it out I would be very interested
to see what kind of information they're
basing their assessment on because
currently the information we have that
is available indicates it was more
likely that it was potentially shot down
right Nick waters from the investigative
journalism collective at Belling Kat
thank you very much for talking to us
and DW thank you very much indeed